hey before the video starts i want to
say thank you to storyblocks
who is the sponsor of today's video
you're going to see a ton of story
blocks footage
in this video because i use storybox
footage in all of my videos
with a subscription to storybox you can
download unlimited
clips that are like high-res and
beautiful and royalty-free for
commercial and personal use
you can also get sound effects and after
effects templates i've been using store
blocks forever because
they're amazing and incredibly cheap and
unlimited downloads
recently storybox hired six lgbtqia plus
directors creators and filmmakers
to build new footage collections for
their library so that these communities
can be authentically represented in
stock footage something that
they traditionally have not been they're
also doing this for other
underrepresented communities
like black indigenous and people of
color you can learn more about this
initiative called restock
as well as go subscribe to storyblocks
and get in on unlimited footage
if you click the link in my description
storybox.com johnny harris clicking that
link
helps support this channel but it also
helps you learn more about
all this cool stuff so thank you
storyblocks and now
enjoy the
[Music]
the video border fence in the world
today is not between
india and pakistan or u.s and mexico or
syria
and turkey those are all very big scary
long fences
but no the longest border fence on earth
looks like this
[Music]
it's 5 600 kilometers long
that's like if you were to draw a border
across the whole united
[Music]
thousand st and this border fence
doesn't even separate
two countries instead this fence
stretches across some of the most remote
territory on earth
it goes through farmlands deserts across
mountain ranges
but unlike most physical barriers that
we use to divide countries to
keep people out this long-ass border was
built to keep out one
very specific thing dingoes
we're here in southeast queensland and
this is the start of the dingo fence
now the dingo bed was established
[Music]
okay can we just say something right up
front do we all agree that
australia is pretty wild and like a
pretty unique place
there's a reason for this back when all
of this was happening
all of these continents were still
attached to one another but down here
australia jumped the gun on the whole
breaking apart thing
and it broke off from all the other land
way earlier than the others
bye [ __ ]
because of this all the plants and
animals on the australian piece of land
evolved in isolation for a really long
time
far away from anything else when we talk
about the seven continents it's like
north america
asia africa and then australia like it's
a country but it's basically its own
continent
this isolation resulted in around 90
of the wildlife in australia being
wholly unique to the continent it
doesn't exist anywhere else
and it stayed this way for a very long
time until
of course these guys showed up
uh another story of these guys
it's always these guys showing up from
europe so the year is 1770. and humans
have been living
on australia for like 70 000 years but
despite this
you get this guy who shows up and claims
possession
of the east coast of australia for the
british crown
soon a bunch of british people are
showing up to australia to set up their
own colony
and this is where the whole pristine
unique ecosystem thing
kind of starts to fall apart so in
addition to what these british people
did
to the native people who were living
there for 70 000 years
massacres as systematic as those
practiced against the jews in the 20th
century the other
thing the europeans did when they
arrived here was they brought all sorts
of plants
and animals and a desire to do farming
all the agriculture stuff that they had
been doing back in europe
meanwhile australia's 120 year old
ecosystem
is like ugh like smh
like we had perfectly balanced our
ecology and these guys are bringing
camels they also start growing a ton of
non-native plants
like sugar and when they started growing
sugar there was one
native species in australia that was
very excited
that native species looked like this
gray back beetle who was stoked about
the fact that these british people were
growing sugar cane
so they just started to feast on all
these sugar farms
so now the europeans now independent
australians
instead of being like hey maybe we
shouldn't grow sugar here because
every time we grow it it gets infested
by these beetles
instead they're like let's go to hawaii
and get a bunch of frogs
the idea is that the frogs would eat the
beetles and then the beetles would go
away
right but no the frogs or the cane toads
specifically had no natural predator in
australia so they just
exploded in their numbers and they
became a pest in and of themselves hey
look those frogs are eating all their
crops
okay one more example here that i have
to tell you about before i get back to
the border fence
one more because i can't not talk about
this so
back in 1932 emus these like big giant
weird birds
were harassing the farmers and so the
australian government sent out
the australian army thousands of
rounds of ammunition to fight these emus
and to kill them off
so that they could control the
population the best part about the story
is that the emus
won the war i honestly i need to make a
video
specifically about the emu wars because
it's just too nuts if you want me to do
that let me know because i
want to do that okay so those are all
the ways in which
the european settlers brought invasive
species to this ecologically unique
place
and sort of started to mess with the
balance one of the big
animals that the british brought over
when they were settling australia
were these guys sheep sheep
have wool and meat and were a big deal
in england and so the australians were
like why not bring them halfway around
the world
to australia and start sheep farming
sheep farming began spreading all around
the country
as europeans settled in australia but
the farmers
started to realize that we're not in
england anymore no i
i know we're not in kansas and their
sheep were starting to disappear
and it turns out that they were being
hunted and eaten by
an animal with a very cool name the
dingo
dingoes are kind of like ancient wild
dogs man ancient wild dogs that should
be like a character
in an anime film it probably already is
dingoes like to eat kangaroos and in
doing so
as per how ecology and natural
food systems work eating the kangaroos
keeps the
kangaroo population at bay and this is
very important
so that we can avoid this happening too
often he's getting mad i'm trying to pet
him
okay yeah i'm videotaping no i'm kidding
that's actually not the reason
why it's important it's important to
keep the kangaroo population at bay
because kangaroos eat vegetation and
plants
and if they grow too large as a
population they'll eat all the plants
they'll mess with the food systems for
other herbivores and the erosion
and the soil content etc etc the whole
ecosystem
relies on this balance of predator and
prey
we are all connected in the great circle
of life so the dingos are important but
the europeans didn't like the dingoes
because they were showing up to the
farms and eating their succulent lamb
chops
this became a big problem and eventually
the farmers are like how am i
supposed to like raise my livestock here
in this wild country with these dingoes
running around eating my sheep
meanwhile australia's 120 million year
old ecosystem is like
deal with it liam the sheep farmer
we've been crafting this wild ecosystem
for
a really long time and we're not gonna
change it just so that you can have your
lamb chops
and liam the sheep farmer's like hold my
beer
excuse me hold my bee
i try not to like do accents because
it's like kind of cliche and
i can't do accents very well but i just
love the way australians say beer there
it is
and thus begins another round of let's
outsmart nature so anyway they start
planting
a fence what if we cut off like a giant
swath of this country
so that all of the dingos stay on that
side of the fence and all the sheep
farmers could stay on this side of the
fence
so they built the fence took them eight
years to construct this
massive fence the longest on earth and
it worked after they completed this
fence sheep deaths plummeted
and so now the farmers are very happy
and the australian government is very
happy because the farmers are happy
meanwhile australia's 120 million year
old ecosystem
is not so happy not happy
damn okay so remember the kangaroos
he's getting mad and i'm trying to pet
him yeah so on this side of the fence
there's now no dingos which means no one
to eat the kangaroos so the population
of kangaroos
skyrockets they start eating all of the
grass and vegetation
this overgrazing has left little food
for the smaller plant-eating animals
whose population is now declining and
now it's also messed with the natural
nutrient cycle of the soil
so now stuff doesn't grow as well in all
of these soils this change in vegetation
made it easier for wind
to pick up sand and create these giant
dunes which then
served as like a wall to redirect the
wind patterns which changes like the
weather patterns etc etc etc
you build one fence to protect sheep
and you trigger a ripple effect that
throws off
a balance in nature that had been
literally hundreds of millions of years
in the making
but to the humans it is very worth it
because the australian sheep industry
is worth 6.6 billion dollars
the reason i'm making this video the
reason i'm fascinated with this fence
isn't just because it's so long
yes i like borders and lines and maps
but
i also see that this fence represents an
overt symbol
of this very european western
human centric notion of humans
controlling nature we can engineer our
way out of anything
the western world has helped create this
global culture
that says that we the humans can do
whatever we need to to serve our needs
whether it's food or shelter
or wool and in the process we can ignore
the needs of every other
organism that shares the environment
with us and what we're seeing
is that there's a cost to this over a
million
different species are set to be extinct
in coming decades because of our
activity because we like to build fences
to protect our sheep
and what's crazy is that it doesn't
totally have to be this way
so much of our modern culture is sort of
a blip on the map like we just started
this idea of going out and engineering
our way out of nature
remember that before the europeans
arrived to australia
the aboriginals had been living there
for 70 000 years
with nature not in spite of it they
didn't need to manipulate it for their
own needs
in a way that threw off the balance of
these ecosystems so far we've been able
to engineer our way out of
quite a lot of things but this
experiment
of breaking away from natural systems is
brand new
and we have no idea how much longer the
natural world will tolerate it before
it really bites back against the humans
and puts us in our place
and maybe this is the wake-up call we
need
to actually start to put into practice
what indigenous communities have known
forever which is that the only way for
long-term survival as a species
is if we learn to share this earth
instead of trying always to dominate it